welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is the 10th lesson of the series and it's the second lesson in the third unit which is on the general
formulation of quantum information this lesson is about channels which represent changes in
systems that store Quantum information this includes useful operations like ones performed by
unitary Gates and Quantum circuits as well as changes that we might prefer to avoid like noise we can also describe measurements
as channels and that's something that we'll get into in the next lesson the term Channel comes to us from
information Theory which among other things studies the information carrying capacity of noisy communication
channels so when we think about channels we're thinking abstractly about communication
channels it might seem kind of odd to think about a complicated computation as a communication Channel but we need a
word to refer to the general notion of a process that changes information in some way and For Better or Worse the word
channel has stuck no doubt due in large part to the enormous impact that information Theory and in particular the
work of Claude Shannon in the 1940s has had on Quantum information and computation here is an overview of the
lesson we'll start with the basics including the definition of what a channel is as well as how unitary operations in the simplified formulation
of quantum information can be described as channels we'll also talk about the fact that convex combinations of channels are channels and if you're
wondering why this notion of convexity keeps coming up it's because it really is a fundamentally important mathematical notion in the theory of
quantum information we'll also see some examples of channels specifically Cubit channels which will reappear from time
to time throughout the remainder of the lesson in the second part of the lesson we'll talk about three different ways that we can represent channels
mathematically and in particular we'll talk about Stein spring representations Krauss representations and Choy
representations which are named after three people whose work was important in the development of these different representations and in the third and
final part of the lesson we'll discuss a mathematical proof that establishes that these three representations are in fact equivalent as well as the fact that they
all correctly characterize the definition of what a channel is it's a really cool mathematical proof in my opinion and hopefully it will add some
clarity to these different presentations how they relate and how they work in general we'll start with the basics and
address the question what are channels as I already suggested at the start of the lesson channels describe changes
specifically discreete time changes in systems that store Quantum information here when we refer to a discrete time
change we're just thinking about a change that occurs between two distinct moments in time as opposed to a
continuous process for instance that makes sense to think about over infinitesimally small time time periods channels include useful operations like
unitary operations that are performed by Quantum Gates and circuits as well as changes due to noise for instance for
the purposes of this lesson though we're mostly going to be thinking about channels in abstract mathematical terms and there won't be any particular need
to distinguish between what's useful and what's not typical names for channels include the uppercase Greek letters fi
Sai andai and we'll use different letters to refer to some specific channels in a simple situation in which
we have some system that's in a state described by some density Matrix row and we apply a channel f to that system the
result is a system whose state is described by the density Matrix fi of row so we're thinking about a given
Channel fi as being a function that can be applied to density matrices of a particular size or in other words
density matrices of a particular system that we're applying this channel to there are a couple of requirements that channels must satisfy in order to be
considered valid channels First channels are linear mappings this is completely analogous to the situation we have both
in the simplified formulation of quantum information where operations on Quantum State vectors are necessarily linear as
well as in the standard formulation of classical information where probabilistic operations are linear you could choose to question this basic
requirement of linearity if you really wanted to but if we want a theory that's consistent with both probability Theory
and the choice to represent Quantum states with density matrices then we don't really have any choice and we just have to accept that channels are linear
the second requirement is that channels transform density matrices into density matrices that makes perfect sense because if we've chosen to represent
states of systems with density matrices and we apply a channel to a system that's in some State then the result has to be a valid State and therefore
represented by a density Matrix there's a very important point to add here though and that is that this requirement
has to be true not only if we apply a channel to an isolated system whose state is described by a density Matrix
but also if we have a compound system whose state is described by some density Matrix and we apply the channel to just
part of that system so those are the requirements that we place on channels and we can see that they are very much
analogous to the requirements that we have for operations in both the simplified formulation of quantum information and the standard formulation
of classical information in the simplified formulation of quantum information operations are represented by unitary matrices because they
correspond precisely to the linear Maps that always transform Quantum State vectors into Quantum State vectors for a
given system and similarly probabilistic operations are represented by stochastic matrices because those are the ones that
always transform probability vectors into probability vectors here we're working with density matrices and there
is this added requirement concerning compound systems that turns out not to be necessary for Quantum State vectors
or probability vectors but otherwise the requirements are analogous and in some sense our forced Upon Us by the choice
to represent Quantum states by density matrices here are some further details about channels including a convention
for how we'll think about the input and output systems of a channel throughout the lesson as well as some more detail
about the requirement that channels always transform density matrices into density matrices first every channel is
assumed to have an input system and an output system we can name these systems however we choose but throughout this
lesson I'm going to use the name X to refer to the input system and the name y to refer to the output system conceptually speaking the channel
transforms the input system into the output system so the input and output systems never simultaneously coexist we
start with x the channel is applied or performed and the result is that X has been transformed into y whose state is
determined by the linear mapping associated with the channel the input and output systems for a channel don't need to be the same and in particular
they don't need to have the same number of classical States however it can be that the input and the output systems are actually the same system or in other